hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
lacking across the board the
government's advisors on climate change
warned that the UK is unprepared for the
impacts of the climate crisis
hundreds of academics urged the prime
minister to end approvals for new oil
and gas projects in the UK
would this be the future of food
scientists grow meat using the cells of
an extinct mammoth
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now the government's own
independent climate advisors are warning
that the UK is strikingly unprepared for
the effects of climate change with
ministers presiding over a lost decade
of preparations in a new report the
climate change committee has said last
Summer's 40 degree Heat Wave and drought
so just how vulnerable the UK is to a
hotter climate without better planning
let's speak now to the chief executive
of that committee Chris Stark Chris
thank you so much for joining us so why
is the UK so unprepared for the effects
of climate change
well that's a very important question
and I'm not sure I have a a very good
answer because we are really seeing the
impacts of climate change playing out
now I mean we'll talk a lot about the
period last summer of course we had that
first ever 40 degree Centigrade day
that's just one of the signals of
climate change there's a host of others
impacts now being felt across the board
right across the year actually and the
UK is not alone in experiencing it but
let's not talk about the UK let's talk
about people living in the country I
think people are now aware of climate
change they understand that we're in the
grip of it and yet we do not have a
program of policies and plans from this
government that is anywhere close to uh
where it needs to be when we look at
that program it's called the national
adaptation program I'm pretty sure that
even the audience for this show is not
one that has read that program because
it's it's sitting away in a Dusty
cupboard somewhere it's a a small bit of
government that has been tasked with
bringing that together and it just does
not have the political Focus that it
really should have so one of the reasons
for publishing a report today we're
doing so well we do one every couple of
years but we did it earlier this year to
try and inform the next program from
this government which is due in the
summer
Chris let's talk about that report well
the report about the national adaptation
program because it's quite Stark it says
that this program fails to match the
scale of the challenge lacks a Clear
Vision isn't underpinned by tangible
outcomes or targets and hasn't driven
policy or implementation how has that
been allowed to happen
well I'm afraid this is the effect of
collectively politicians and politics
not grasping the challenge now I
understand that I understand that
politics doesn't want to look into this
and actually grab the size of it but we
really do need a political class that's
ready to to tackle this properly now we
can't dock this anymore sadly for too
long we've been thinking about this as
something for a future term of office
you know climate change is something
that will happen in the future or even
worse climate change is something that
will happen to other parts of the world
and not to us none of that is true of
course climate change is with us now and
even if it is happening somewhere else
we're also exposed to that too just
think about the empty shelves that we've
seen this year that's the kind of impact
that comes from extreme weather climate
related impacts to supply chains in this
country that's just one of these impacts
so this is such an all-encompassing
thing it feels to me very strange that
we haven't had politics tackle this uh
in a more extreme way in a more direct
way I think we've been looking a lot at
the challenge of Net Zero of course and
very very very important goal of
reaching Net Zero globally and reaching
Net Zero in the UK now it seems to me is
the time to raise the need to do the
other bits of this which is of course to
achieve Net Zero but also to adapt to
the economy adapt to society to the
change in the climate that we know is
coming remember if we hit Net Zero
globally by the middle of the century
that will broadly keep us in in some
shape or form on track for the
temperature Targets in the Paris
agreement but that means that we will
have to see continuing warming for two
decades possibly three decades or more
over that period so this is something
that's really now very very important
and then there's a window for us to act
on it if we don't take it of course
we're going to regret it later you have
laid out a clear path for the government
to improve the country's climate
resilience how optimistic are you that
they are actually going to follow that
path
well I'm not sure that I am optimistic
but I am positive about the ability for
us to do something about it again one of
the reasons for publishing a report
early in the year this time is that we
wanted to give the government a bit of
time to prepare for that we've had two
national adaptation programs uh covering
the last decade and more we refer to
that as a lost decade because they
haven't really uh grabbed the grabbed
the issue in the way that they should if
anything what they're doing is kind of
hoovering up a set of things that the
government was already doing and putting
them in one place that's not a real
program uh you know that's a description
of things that were already happening
it's not a surprise to me that the
things that we have acted on in this
country have been the things that the
politicians feel the most pressure on
and that's why flooding is an issue that
has been grasped uh you know of course
there's more to do in flooding but it's
one of course that gets more attention
we need to give the same attention to
other areas so this next program is
coming up in the government it's during
the summer at some point it's led by
defra and I think really important we've
set out what we think we need to see in
that there's some really useful advice
there for the government if they want to
take it if the government doesn't take
it and I think we're into a different
world of actually dialing up the
criticism still further and asking
questions about whether deffer itself is
able to cope with these kind of
important National issues okay Chris
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak to us
thank you
all right let's take a look at some of
those other stories now and the European
Court of Human Rights is to consider two
cases of European governments accused of
failing to protect the environment in
Switzerland more than 2 000 people are
claiming the government's climate change
policies are risking their health and
their living conditions and in France a
former mayor is accusing the government
of taking insufficient steps to prevent
climate change
a new study has found that microplastic
pollution along the country's coastline
is a hundred times the level it was six
years ago the data was collected last
summer by teams competing in the GB
rowing challenge around the UK
scientists at the University of
Portsmouth then analyzed the samples
using new technology that allowed them
to get a more accurate picture of
pollution levels
now to demonstrate the potential of a
lab-grown meat an Australian company has
created this it's a meatball using the
genetic code of a woolly mammoth the
project aims to show the potential of
creating meat products without the
slaughter of animals the company called
Val hopes the technology could help
vastly reduce the huge environmental
impact of meat production would you eat
that is the question
hundreds of academics have sent a letter
to the Prime Minister Rishi sunak urging
him to end approvals for all new oil and
gas developments it comes on the eve of
a planned government announcement on
energy security and Net Zero the letter
has been signed by 700 experts from
universities and research bodies across
the UK it says approving new oil fields
like the proposed Rose Bank project of
Shetland would undermine the UK's
position as a global climate leader well
let's speak to someone who's actually
signed that letter Professor Emily
shutberg who's the director of Cambridge
xero at the University of Cambridge
Emily thank you so much for talking to
us so why have you signed this letter
and what are you hoping it achieves
well the um ipcc came out last Monday to
say that there is a rapidly closing
windows to secure a livable future for
all and we just heard from Chris stocks
how we're seeing those impacts of
climate change playing out uh in the UK
and across the world today in that
context
um we really want it as the climate
research Community to send a very strong
statement to the government that it is
simply incompatible with our national
and international response to climate
change to be looking at this time to um
to open up new fossil fuel
infrastructure the ipcc was very clear
in fact that emissions from existing
fossil fuel infrastructure without
additional abatements such as carbon
capture and storage would be sufficient
to exhaust the budget to keep
temperatures below 1.5 degrees of
warming what do you make of the argument
that if we do stop the new development
of oil and gas there will be real
concerns about both the affordability
and the security of our energy supplies
which is something that we have seen
this year already isn't it
well absolutely both the affordability
and the security of supplies are an
incredibly important
um element to consider but uh the
absolute uh most powerful way of
securing affordability and security of
Supply is to really look at enhancing
our our renewable technologies that we
already have in place whether that's
solar or
um wind and enhancing the the necessary
storage technologies that are associated
with that we know how to
um how to produce uh our energy needs
without fossil fuels and another really
critical element of that of course is
looking at Energy Efficiency how we can
improve the insulation of our homes
which we know is something that is
really poor in the UK and therefore
reduce our dependency
um on our fossil fuel infrastructure so
what do you make of the proposed Rose
Bank oil-filled off the Shetland Islands
well you know I think just the fact that
we had so much uh so many people from
the UK uh academic Community
signed this letter to the Prime Minister
sends a really strong statement that as
I say it is just scientifically
incompatible with our climate response
and our and our duty to take uh
leadership uh National and International
Leadership associated with this to be
looking to expand fossil fuel
infrastructure at this time okay Emily
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you
now pool Harbor was the subject of a
damaging oil leak earlier this week
raising fears about the impact on
wildlife in an area of special
scientific interest our data and
forensics unit has been looking into
what happened Adam Parker reports
something of an environmental disaster
happening out here and nobody seems to
know what's happening a major incident
was declared on Sunday after around 20
000 liters of reservoir fluid leaked
from a pipeline in Dorset the fluid made
up of 85 water and 15 oil came from our
Bay into poor Harbor
tidal so the leaked oil will have been
moving into surrounding Waters
the witch Farm onshore oil field is the
largest in Western Europe it's operated
by parenko the main Gathering station is
here with crude oil extracted for more
than 10 well sites
pipelines connecting them run around two
to three meters Underground
Sky News understands the leak occurred
here next to Well site D bubbling water
was spotted indicating oil was rising
from below ground
the view from the Gathering station
across the harbor shows the area
immediately affected by The Spill on the
far side two miles from the leak this
video is filmed from hamworthy Park and
this was taken at Paul key also on the
other side of the harbor
at the leaked location as part of the
cleanup operation a floating skimmer is
being used to extract the oil from the
surface
it's being pumped into this portable
tank and extracted by the tanker
Downstream closer to poor Harbor
booms are being used to stop the spread
further and contain the spill
people are being told to stay out of the
water and while the full environmental
impact is not yet known the rspb says
oil birds have been spotted around the
harbor
this shell duct was showing signs of
contamination at lichit Bay more than
four miles from the leak
we don't know yet exactly how the leak
happened but the government says a full
investigation will take place
Adam Parker
Sky News
before we go a reminder that we want
your climate questions anything that's
ever mystified you about the environment
or whatever you want to get to the
bottom of
scan this QR code and send us your
questions which we will answer in the
climate Show with Tom Heap
as you can watch Tom's show on Saturday
and Sunday at 3 P.M here on Sky News
that's all from us today thank you so
much for watching
foreign